[Music]
what up guys goes on here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about everything you need to
know about the most powerful technology
in attack on Titan the coordinate power
before we get to that as always I want
to thank you guys for watching and for
your unbelievable support you guys are
always liking commenting and it made us
realize how blessed we are because we
get to make videos about anime we love
and then we get to share them with all
of you I really can't thank you guys
enough if you guys have any suggestions
for videos please leave them in the
comment section below and if you're new
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell because there are many
more attack on Titan videos on the way
as always guys there will be manga
spoilers so either prepare to have your
mind blown or turn away right now for
the brave souls still with me let's
uncover some Titan secrets the
coordinate is first mentioned in chapter
47 of the manga entitled children Rainer
and vert old have kidnapped Eren and
Amir and are hanging out on a tree
waiting for the night to immobilize the
Titans and Rana reveals that their
mission is to find and bring back the
coordinate which they think might be
Eren
but if it isn't then their mission won't
be over yet so what is this coordinate
Rainer is talking about well let's get
into it other names for the coordinate
that are used in the manga are the
founding Titan founder power the Titans
and scream supposedly all LD ends are
connected imagined invisible strings and
all of these connections come together
at a single point they are all connected
to the coordinate aka DL Dean who has
the founding Titan power as a result the
founding Titan can use the connection to
manipulate Aldean's in terms of their
minds and memories or Titans in terms of
their actions the coordinate or founding
Titan is actually one of the nine titan
powers along with the attack titan
female Titan Colossus Titan armored
Titan beast Titan the jaws Cartman and I
yet to be revealed ninth Titan power by
the way let me know what you think the
night Titan power will be in the
comments section below I really enjoy
reading your guys's theories the
coordinate is asthma
above the most powerful of all nine
Titans and as is the case with these
other Titans to coordinate has its own
unique abilities it has three main ones
that we know of the possessor of the
coordinate power can control the actions
of other Titans and make them follow
virtually any order this is probably why
artistic depictions of a mere fritz the
first founding titan include a war horn
it represents the screen-based trigger
that allows the possessor to command
other Titans rod Reese has stated that
the founding tines ability is so
powerful that one could wipe out all of
the Titans if they were able to use its
full strength other Titan shifters
seemed to possess similar abilities for
example the female Titan has screamed
and attracted tightness to her in that
way while the Beast Titan can turn
people into Titans by injecting them
with his spinal fluid and then releasing
a scream these Titans follow his
commands although the control is not
perfect and these Titans can even move
by moonlight it is important to note
however that Zeke's abilities surpass
the abilities of the previous possessors
of the Beast Titan probably because he
has royal blood
although female Titans and especially
the Beast Titans abilities are
incredibly useful these powers pale in
comparison to the absolute control that
can in theory be practiced by the
coordinate second the coordinate can
erase and rewrite the memories of LD
ants in the majority bloodline this can
work on entire countries or on an
individual basis as when Frieda Reese
used to erase the story as memories
after hanging out with her it is
important to note that the Ackermann
bloodline the asian clan and the noble
families are immune to this mental
manipulation third the current possessor
as long as they are of royal blood
inherits the memories of all individuals
who previously possess the coordinate
with perfect clarity
possessors may even inherit the memories
of amir fritz the first titan which
would be amazing i am insanely curious
about amir fritz and I really hope that
Aaron starts to remember more about her
life soon although other tightener
shifters also remember some memories
from their past possessors this cannot
be compared to the perfect clarity that
is
supposed to come with the founding Titan
powers people who have possessed the
power include Emir fritz the 104th king
or sometimes referred to as the first
king of the walls mr. Reiss historias
grandfather Yuri Reis historias uncle
Frieda Reese historians half-sister
Grisha Yeager and finally Eren Yeager
our protagonist now let's get into some
Titan history supposedly around 2,000
years ago
Amir Fritz made a deal with the devil
and became the first of all Titans even
though all nine Titan powers are
supposed to have been passed down from a
mere she's always associated with the
power of the founding Titan which is the
most powerful one although the other a
Titan powers went to different familial
houses the power of the court and it
stayed within the Fritz family only
members of this royal bloodline could
fully use the powers of the founding
Titan so for the next 1700 years
the coordinate remained within the royal
Fritz family who despite conflict
maintained order within the LDN Empire
through the use of the founding Titans
incredible powers
however the hundred and forty fifth king
chose to abandon the conflicts of aldia
and move the capital to the island of
paradise where the main attack on titan
story takes place with his founding
titan powers he used countless colossus
titans to create the three walls Maria
rose and Sheena
after king fritz left the nation of
marley waged war against the LD ins that
remained and stole seven of the nine
titan powers they took over all LD and
territory on the continent and while
some escaped to parodies other LD ins
remained and were subject to cruel
treatment and discrimination by the
Marlon population king fritz used the
founding Titans powers to erase the
memory of those aliens who came to
paradise and may them believe that they
were the last humans in a world overrun
by Titans wanting peace King fritz
warned a nation of Marley that if they
attacked parodies he would use the
coordinator to unleash the millions of
Colossus Titans in the walls and
flattened the entire earth a threat
which illustrates the great power of the
coordinate King fritz also made it so
that every
subsequent descendant of the royal
family and inheritor of the founding
titan would adopt his ideology and
allowed the titans to rule over the
humans inside the walls even people like
Yuri Reiss who wanted to use the power
to help humanity defeat the Titans
changed his mind after he inherited the
founding Titan now it is unclear whether
the possessors of this power have no
choice but to succumb to the 145th Kings
ideology or whether the godlike
understanding of the world that comes
along with inheriting the memories and
knowledge of the previous possessors
causes the individual to change their
mind because they can see the situation
clearer than they could before which
leads them to realize that being ruled
by the Titan is the best option for the
LDN people I really look forward to
learning more about why exactly every
member of the royal family who has
acquired that power has adopted the
Kings ideology and refused to explain
why anyways the fritz now called Reese
family continued to pass down the
coordinate from generation to generation
until Freda Reese Rod Reese's daughter
lost it to Grishka Yeager who wanted to
help both the ldiots inside and outside
of the walls Grisha used the power of
the attack Titan that he got from air
and Krueger
to defeat the inexperienced Freda after
killing Freda and the rest of the Reese
family except for Audrey's Grisha
injected Eren with a Titan serum and was
eaten by Aaron who is now the current
possessor of both the attack and
founding Titans
although Eren is the current possessor
of the coordinate his control over it is
far from perfect
because he does not have royal blood the
power virtually lies dormant in Aaron
except for a few instances where
conditions were right and Aaron was able
to use its power when Aaron escapes from
his kidnappers Rainer and bertolt he
sees the smiling Titan that killed his
mother although it is unknown at the
time this is the Titan Adina Fritz who
was a member of the royal family and
grisha's first wife interestingly enough
when Aaron punches the Titans hand and
makes contact with the royal bloodline
the founding Titan power activates as a
result Eren is able to make the
surrounding horde of titans attack
Dina's Titan
and chase after Raiders armored Titan
later on Aaron and his story are
captured by rod Reese who wants the
story to eat Aaron so that she can
unlock the coordinate powers and become
the god of this world when rod and
historia placed her royal hands on
Aaron's body Aaron's coordinate powers
are unlocked briefly for a second time
and he is able to clearly remember
Frida's memories and he sees Grisha
taking the founding titan power five
years ago now the question is how our
aaron's coordinate power is going to
evolve and manifest in the future he
hasn't revealed to the government inside
the walls that he was able to use the
power when he came into contact with a
Titan of royal blood because he fears
for historians fate
how will Aaron be able to make use of
these titan powers in the future if
contact with historia is needed to
partially unlock the power is it
possible that pills with historias blood
will do the trick as some of you
suggested on the other videos I'm not
sure how they're going to harness the
power of the court in it but I would
love to hear what you guys think in the
comments section below if historian does
in fact have royal blood then she should
be able to use the coordinate after she
becomes a Titan in devours Aaron but
this wouldn't really solve anything
says chances are that she would adopt
the passive non-interventionist ideology
of the first king like every other
member of the royal bloodline did
because of this it seems like the best
bet for the LD ins inside the walls
would be for Aaron to figure out how to
unlock the powers himself because he
does not seem to be affected by the
first Kings ideology and that is it for
today's video thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you found this
information as interesting as I did
while researching it I can't wait to
find out more as we go on with the manga
if you did enjoy the video be sure to go
frits mode on that like button and
subscribe for many more attack on Titan
videos until next time see ya space
cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]